I guys, Tim Ferriss here, I am
asked a lot about evening routines,
so I'm going to show you what my
current routine looks like pre bed.
So let's say that I'm about 60 minutes
out. I want to go to bed 60 minutes.
I am going to make myself some tea.
There's decaffeinated these days.
It is Douglas first spring
tip by Juniper Ridge.
The stuff right here.
It is fantastic.
I first bought it at the San Francisco
very building farmer's market,
which is on Thursdays and Saturdays.
This stuff has become a real favorite.
Now into that t once I've
steeped it and taken out the bag,
I will put in apple cider vinegar,
one or two tablespoons
and then I will also put,
this is assuming I'm having trouble
sleeping and need to get to sleep and a
tablespoon of unfiltered honey.
All right,
this is a tip borrowed from my late friend
Seth Roberts and amazing guy and I am
not a hundred percent sure on the
biochemistry behind why this works,
but it knocks you out like that.
Many of my friends who are chronic
insomniacs have credited this with better
sleep than even prescription medications.
So I'm not a doctor,
don't play one on the Internet, so stay
on your meds, talk to your doctors, blah,
blah, blah. But this combination of
apple cider vinegar plus the honey,
which I would just add to this tea, is
literally a knockout. It's incredible.
Now at that point I will turn on my
downstairs soaking tub and we're going to
get some footage of that in a second.
That takes about 15 minutes to fill and
I'll sit down and I'll read fiction,
right?
I'm not going to read something like a
nonfiction business book that's going to
keep my problem solving apparatus
in sixth gear. That's not helpful.
I need to turn that off.
So I'll read fiction.
This is a book that I just finished,
which was recommended to me by a
billionaire investor named Chris Sacca,
who's also a friend and has been on the
podcast on the Tim Ferriss show and it
is called how to get filthy rich
in rising Asia by, I'm guessing,
pronounced Mohsin Hamid. This
is a fantastic book. I mean,
it is just incredible. Uh,
pros, so pure and purposeful.
It passes straight through
into the bloodstream.
It intoxicates the New
York Times book review,
a globalized version of the great Gatsby.
His book is nearly that good. NPR,
it's fantastic and very hilarious.
So I just finished this fiction.
Then that point,
I'll set an alarm.
Let's say it's 13 minutes in,
I will fill up this thermos effectively
with water and a ton of ice.
Now this hydroflask 40 ounce hydroflask
is also something I traveled with.
Why?
This is actually kind of cool
because it doubles as a foam roller,
but it's not fun.
So I will use this to actually roll out
my hip flexors and whatnot when I'm on
the road and it saves me,
they filled with packing both.
So I can just clip this onto my carry
on with the carabiner and off I go. No,
I have this,
which is going to be a core,
literally core component
of thermoregulation. And
then I had downstairs,
it says we're going next.
So here we are downstairs,
got the Houdini, you have
all sorts of other artwork.
This room used to be just like a
dirty futon room with a playstation.
The previous owners didn't
know what to do with it.
So I stripped out everything and I built
something that I've wanted since I was
15 and lived in Japan and had a nightly,
oh Hoodo.
So this is what it looks like.
And uh,
try not to completely kill
lighting here,
but if you come in
you can see that this has
been made into my spa room,
effectively complete with the shelves,
with towels and everything.
So this is a soaking tub.
And
each night I would get in here,
I have my ice water.
This will sit at this point right here.
I have a thermometer. If I really
want to check water temperature,
because I know sometimes alternate this
with ice baths in the other room. And uh,
then you have steps that
give you a different depths.
So I can go from about here
to here to here. All right,
now there are no jets.
This is not a Jacuzzi.
This is a soaking tub.
And to that end, I have
a bunch of stuff in here and these
are different types of Epsom salts and
medicinal salts that are in
dog food rolling containers.
So this is Epsom salts are magnesium
sulfate that I buy bulk and I will just
take two gigantic glasses worth or jars,
mirth of this and put it into the tub.
I also have
a number of different oils and so
on that depending on my training,
I can use a,
and if we come around the corner here,
you can see that we have
cozy little sauna.
So this is a dry sauna for two people.
It's a tight fit.
You could get someone on the floor
also if they're a little overheated.
And I will play with this for not only
just regular Banya should sing purposes,
but also for increasing endurance.
Uh, and if you're interested in that,
you can look up Rhonda
Patrick, rh, O, n, d,
a Rhonda Patrick Phd and a Sauna.
And Ferris,
there's an entire 10 page post on how to
use heat exposure for a growth hormone
increases and improved endurance.
And that is in effect my evening routine.
So it starts upstairs and down here.
I will consume the ice water every
two or three cycles into that bath.
I'll usually listen to an audio book
of some type or presentations that are
motivational in some capacity and then
shower and off to bed and having already
had the cocktail with the apple
cider vinegar and the honey.
I'm out like a light.
I am a lifelong insomniac and I no longer
have it sent me in part due to having
a consistent nightly ritual.
Did you like this?
If you like this, you're
going to love what's waiting
right here. Click subscribe.
I have some amazing stuff coming.